Firewatch local developers camposanto
yes finally released their inaugural
game anticipated very much so it's been
it seems have been previewed at a bunch
of events for years and years and we
finally got to play it's scott you were
reviewed its antenna on gamespot com yes
good but not great basically yeah there
are certain parts of the game that are
like a nine or a ten that is just
something I've never seen a game support
that are beautifully executed just the
writing and and really the characters
are unlike anything that I've ever
played and really kind of only directing
the relationship between the two main
characters is something you could kind
of only do in a game and having the
control and the ability to sort of shape
this dynamic and to read this really
thoughtful insight into the way that a
meaningful relationship is formed is
really just special it really is
unfortunately not all over the game is
quite as special as that relationship
and it kind of stumbles in certain ways
and so yeah ultimately it landed at a
seven I I feel like that score suggests
like it's okay when really it's like no
other things it does a lot of stuff
really good there are things that aren't
so good it just kind of balances out and
ends up being a seven in the end so
hopefully people who are interested so
give it a chance cuz I really did enjoy
a great deal yeah seems super unique
like I guess that we had Steve Gaynor in
a couple of weeks ago we're talking
about the rise of the walking simulator
and why not sure and it seems like it's
it's that it'd be a bit reductive to say
it's it's like gone home but it's quite
linear is all right Mary you completed
it last night right yeah I just finished
it and i would i would actually compare
it very much to God alone yeah its way
in the sense that you this is a it's got
a destination you can't deviate too much
from it you're going to get to an end
result but you know the way you
experience your character and the way
you interpret other characters is up to
you and so it's about taking the
narration the narrative and in deciding
what kind of person you are who are you
playing because you're making choices
right like does the sort of the demo
we've seen a lot of which is the you
know come up with the girls in the the
pond and do you like throw their stereo
in the pond or do you just shout at them
or do you just turn it off does those
decisions do they make meaningful
impacts Mary not that I found and I
think that's you know we're being I'm
being a little
I go on purpose yes because this is a
short game and I don't want to ruin it
for anyone but as vague as i can say
that most of my decisions didn't really
change anything and that can maybe upset
people but then you can take a step back
and reflect on it and realize that the
things that you take away with our new
person you played as and the people that
you talked to and what that meant to you
and that like Scott said it's it's very
powerful like the relationship and that
has two tremendous writing and really
good acting right boy seconds so good
hey you love you so much therefore lon
seduces little inflections in the way
lines are deliver you can really like
read a lot into the way things are said
just the tone and like just these
subtleties and the way lines are
delivered is really really brilliant
yeah we are we are kind of identity to
do the impossible by at all on day
release because it's really worth it is
extremely story driven so right even you
know talking about it broadly almost
feels like a spoiler like in the review
I talk about how I felt like the central
mystery doesn't totally pay off and even
that to me almost feels like a spoiler
in a way right even though that's not
specific at all but but I know germania
any anyway when any game this small and
he's sort of not not in any direction as
a giveaway so let's yeah let's maybe
reel it back from the story stuff you
guys have explained it very well and
let's talk about this stuff we don't
mind about spoiling a technical issues
so I want to ask Mary in a second she's
fresh off the boat when it comes two
days you played the last week and you
had some problems on PC less so no on
ps4 correct less so on PC and Joshua as
well just saw one of our video editors
that also played the game and also
experienced the same problems that I
that I had I mean like I described it in
the review persistent minor but
persistence nothing that's really going
to break the game for you but stuff that
is like a little annoying specifically
on PS were the one problem that
persisted through the entire game is any
time we hit a like a new section of the
map or the game was auto saving you
would notice a note there was a
noticeable framerate stutter alright so
the game would kind of chug for about a
second and then things would be fine but
in a game that's all about emergent
emergent and atmosphere yeah it kind of
takes you out of the experience but
every couple minutes it's like okay
there's the load icon it's a okay um so
it would have been really nice if it
hadn't been the case doesn't
happened nearly as often on pc still
happens sometimes in pc kind of has its
own issues yeah um also had a couple
crashes I mean Josh Josh's game crashed
three times i guess my crashed why so I
mean again it's not you know something
to the world I don't really lose much
progress but yeah it's just something
something worth noting if you're if
you're getting into the game and
hopefully mary had a better games and I
did I did ruinous but it was just worth
noting hmm I played it on pc 0 crashes
and maybe like a few starters that
didn't really bother me and which is
really good for my experience because
you're right it's incredibly immersive
and it's so beautiful and they're these
long stretches where you're just walking
through the woods and just fine and it's
so beautiful yeah it's a huge part of it
right is that you're just you're just
walking through the woods thinking about
stuff you know yeah feelings and
thinking thought and slowly and surely
music builds in the background comes up
thinking music you know and so you're
just walking in the woods thinking about
your life like I've done this like I'm
playing the long dark and then the
witness came Ella I feel like walking
through what beautiful woods is like the
the way of 2016 already I mean solutely
a few games so far for sure yeah all
right let's get right down to it
obviously you guys the reviews on the
side both of you seem to have enjoyed it
quite a lot and is this a game do you
think people should pick up straight
away it's 1999 normally on steam at 17
night tonight at the moment ten percent
off launch week proper lunch window sale
yeah Mary what did you think was it was
it worth the time how much time did you
spend on it and I actually burn through
yeah run through burned through it you
did its number two on the show I didn't
do that on purpose and the Fire Emblem
coming up next so higher puns are so hot
hot show oh my god no sorry really
really sorry anyway I burned through it
in like three and half four hours which
is really quick okay uh but I really did
enjoy those hours I don't think this
game is for everyone and I say that
because you said this in your view you
know if you are looking for puzzles and
you know quick time events or gameplay
mechanics that you learn and then
manipulate this game doesn't have any of
them you should go into this game
understanding what it is this game is a
narrative
story-driven experience that you walk
through you'll never you know be tested
or tried in terms of gameplay it's
strictly just about you playing this
dude and some stuff happens to them and
you decide how he handles it it's like
they're easy yeah whether he's angry or
stuff out that's happening you play a
dude is like deeper in this game it is
it is beautiful and so I do want to come
on a compliment like how gorgeous it is
it's very thought provoking and
interesting but it's not for everyone
and you know that's have appropriate
expectations that's right if you like
those types of games you know if you
like everybody's gone to the rapture be
ready for that kind of experience yeah I
mean even if you played a bunch of
telltale adventure games this game
doesn't even have the QuickTime events
you would normally find in those rice
game yeah it really is a very
deliberately paced you know kind of a
slow burn sorry no I can't I can't hold
on you go there in the going and even
though I mean there's actually a really
interesting conversation you could have
about player agency in this game and how
much of an impact you have but then
you're really getting into spoiler
territory so I'll just say that okay I
took a little more time with it my first
playthrough lasted about seven hours
because I really just wandered through
and enjoyed the world and soaked
everything in I feel like I really got a
lot out of it even though the central
mystery again doesn't really build up I
think that the process of building the
relationship between Henry Lee Henry and
Delilah the two main characters in the
game it was again just something I've
never really experienced anywhere else
and in a game or anywhere and it was
truly beautiful with really unique and
for me that makes it absolutely
worthwhile and I'm also you know
generally inclined to be like hey this
is a passion project this was you know a
smaller team doing something really cool
and right I think that's in my mind
commendable I'm you know I'm not gonna
tell it like rush out and buy it right
now but I mean as far as things you can
spend your money on it seems like a
pretty good one to me yeah a lot of
reasons recommend Scott Butterworth
thank you so much for coming in
absolutely a minute on gamespot com
folks and go read that review yes I wish
you unwatched had a woman to reveal we
got a one minute we on facebook we
didn't want to do the full full review
we normally do BK really talked about it
for ten minutes without spoiling yeah
exactly it's so like you couldn't show
much of that game without spoiling
everything that we didn't do a full
review just the one minute but it's on
facebook so go watch that and it's also
spoiler free yes completely clean go for
it
all right Scott thanks so much Mary you
stick around because we're gonna talk
about dr. Tony in a second